I must be in love I can't stop thinking
about this person I know he's toxic but
I can't stop thinking I'm watching when
he's online if they're preoccupied with
someone and they're thinking about them
all day every day and they're trying to
control their behavior and they're
watching them they mistake that
preoccupation as love when really it's a
signal it's a signal to show that your
trauma alarm has been activated this
person is not soothing you or you are
finding the problems in this
relationship but either way it's not a
symbol of love it's a symbol that
something's wrong it's a signal that you
haven't been able to soothe yourself or
this relationship is not soothing so we
have to dissect which one it is is it
the person or is it your own anxiety